SPEAKER: Google
Kubernetes Engine
helps you focus on
your application
while still being able
to configure details
of how your app can run.
When it comes to
cost optimization,
you can fine-tune both your
application and your GKE
configuration, getting the most
value for what you're spending
and reducing wasted resources.
Today we'll talk about some
tips and best practices
for the application
side of that.
Let's go beyond your GKE bill.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the past few
videos, we've spent
a lot of time looking
at optimizing GKE
through monitoring, machine
types, autoscaling, and more.
If you haven't watched
the previous videos,
I'd suggest checking
those out first,
since a lot of specific
optimization tips in this video
and the next builds on
those previous concepts.
We're talking all
about apps today.
So I'll start with
the resource side,
then move on to some
best practices for how
to build your containers.
After that, we'll
talk about some ways
to make sure that your
app and Kubernetes are
working well together.
The best way to start
is to repeat this.
It is critical to know the
details of your application
and how it responds to demand.
Monitoring can help
understand what resources
are used as demand increases.
We covered monitoring earlier,
but here's another tip.
Try running your application
as a single pod replica
and then test it under load
without any autoscaling.
Once you have that
information, use
it to configure resource
requests and limits, which
we'll talk about in a minute.
Then test your app again
with cluster autoscaling
and horizontal or
vertical autoscaling.
Now test large, rapid
spikes in demand
to see how your app responds.
No matter which tool you
use to stimulate demand,
try to use the
same region or zone
as where your app is running.
That way you can
minimize latency
and focus on understanding
all the details of how
your app scales.
And there's more you can
do with that knowledge.
Earlier in the
monitoring video, we
talked about resource
quotas and limit ranges.
You can also set
resource requests
and use limit ranges
to control resources.
With a resource
request, you're defining
how many resources
your application
actually needs to run.
With a resource
limit, you're defining
the maximum amount of
resources that your app
is allowed to use.
These will help
Kubernetes figure out
how to schedule
your pods and ensure
that they don't use up all the
resources that are on the node.
One best practice is
to set your memory
limit equal to
your memory request
and to set your CPU limit
higher than your CPU request.
Or you can even
leave it unbounded.
Kubernetes can always
throttle the CPU
that your pods are using
down to the request amount
if the CPU resources
are in high demand.
But the same doesn't
work for memory,
since Kubernetes needs to
shut down pods when scaling
and if there's too much
demand on the memory.
Of course, any
form of autoscaling
might not be very useful if
your application can't scale.
Vertical autoscaling,
it's only effective
if your application can actually
use the additional resources
on the nodes.
In the same way,
horizontal autoscaling
is only effective if additional
pod replicas actually let
your app handle more demand.
If the actual
performance bottleneck
is on something like
a required database,
more pods might actually
make the problem worse.
Either way, you can use
the different autoscaling
techniques that we went
over in the previous videos
to make a configuration that
works best for your app.
But if your app can't
scale, you might
need to consider refactoring
to a structure that works well
with Kubernetes.
For example,
single-threaded apps or apps
that can only run a limited
number of concurrent processes
may not get much value out
of the extra resources.
If your app can
scale, the next step
is to look at spinning
up and spinning down.
Here's some best practices
for minimizing startup times.
Whenever the cluster
autoscaler creates a new node,
that node has to download
the base image for each app
that it'll run.
The smaller your image is, the
faster a node can download it.
In the same way, use
the smallest base image
that your app
actually needs to run.
Also try to minimize the
amount of startup time needed
to start handling requests.
Startup tasks like
loading classes and caches
can significantly increase the
amount of time between creation
and then being ready, which
could cause requests to fail
while your app is spinning up.
Check out the best
practices for building
containers link
in the description
below for more information.
On the other side,
you want to make sure
that your app can
shut down gracefully.
If your workload has
trouble shutting down,
it can lead to delays and
disruptions in service.
When a pod is going
to be shut down,
it should receive a SIGTERM.
Instead of just assuming
that everything is done,
this is actually a signal
to do some cleanup.
First of all, you want to update
your readiness probe to fail.
More on that coming soon.
So that request will
stop coming into the pod
if you're using container native
load balancing, which we'll
talk about in the next video.
But your pod must still
finish all the active requests
and any new ones that come in,
since it can take a bit of time
for Kubernetes to update
where those requests are
going to be delivered to.
In addition to that, your pod
should run any cleanup steps
like persisting any
in-memory state.
If you're not handling
SIGTERM or you
can't because your app is
using a system that you don't
actually have control
over, like a web
server or a reverse proxy,
you can use the preStop hook.
Here your pod can
run the same cleanup,
and you can even put a sleep
command in for a few seconds
to postpone the SIGTERM.
There's also a configuration to
give your pods a bit more time
to shut down.
It's called
terminationGracePeriodSeconds.
You should only change
this if you really need it.
By default, it's
set to 30 seconds,
but it can go all the way up to
10 minutes before the cluster
autoscaler forcibly
terminates it.
Quick startups and
proper shutdowns
help your autoscalers work in a
more reliable, more efficient,
and cost optimized way.
The more specific you configure
GKE to your application,
the better it can run it.
In the first video, we talked
about pod disruption budgets,
when you statically set the
minimum number of pad replicas
to keep your app running.
Kubernetes will try
to respect that number
as it handles rollouts,
upgrades, and autoscaling.
It's not a guarantee when
unexpected things happen,
but it's still a best practice
to define pod disruption
budgets for every application.
That way your app
will almost always
have enough replicas to
keep running effectively.
In addition to those
budgets, you'll
also want to make sure
that you're correctly
setting readiness and
liveness probes for your app.
Kubernetes will use
the readiness probe
to know if each pod is
ready to handle traffic.
So you don't need to worry about
race conditions between traffic
and setup time.
Liveness probes are used
to tell if the pod is
still alive and working.
So if your application
gets stuck or deadlocked,
Kubernetes knows to restart it.
These two probes are key to
making sure that Kubernetes can
optimize working with your app.
And here are some best
practices for working with them.
Always define readiness
probes for every container.
Know when your application
is actually ready.
For example, if your app
depends on a cache being loaded,
the readiness probe
should only say
the pod is ready after
that cache has been loaded.
If your app doesn't
need any startup time,
define a simple readiness
probe, such as just returning
HTTP 200.
Also make sure the
code for your probes
is as simple and
isolated as possible
so there's no blockers
when Kubernetes
is requesting the status.
Your probe logic should try
to avoid remote services.
And if you have to
use something remote,
try to test against the simplest
and hopefully fastest one.
One more best practice for
any and all of your services
is to consider how
to handle retries.
Especially in a full
microservices environment,
a service call could fail
for any number of reasons,
like a network failure
or rate limits.
When there's a
failure, it usually
makes sense to retry
the request in case
it was something temporary.
But if it's more
permanent, you may end up
sending lots of requests
and potentially even
overwhelming the destination.
For both the way
you call services
and the way you create
your own services,
use exponential backoff to
protect against overwhelming
the service.
In short, you just
add a bit of time
after the first failure and then
more if there's another failure
and continue exponentially.
When calling a service, you can
implement exponential backoff
logic yourself, use a library,
or even use Istio or Anthos
Service Mesh that support
a proxy level retry which
handles it all for you.
If your service is
the one being called,
you can rate limit requests
from the same caller
to force exponential backoff.
You'll also want
to prepare yourself
for handling retry requests so
you don't end up duplicating
functionality in a bad way.
Bank transactions, for example.
Of course, the specific details
of how to implement that
will depend on your application.
These are some things
to keep in mind when
working with your application,
and each one will give you
different results.
The key here is to really
have your application and GKE
work together as
efficiently as possible.
On the next video, we'll look
at tips for optimizing GKE
and do a wrap-up.
Remember to check out the
link in the description
for the full guide on
GKE cost optimization.
[MUSIC PLAYING]